so what do you think would happen the
next day let's say we discover life
it's proxima centauri b
it's um
it looks just like slime mold like you
get on your you know brie cheese or
whatever
we discover what would happen the next
day
and they were like oh this would be
transformative and and i'm not trying to
be like you know total cassandra about
this but i said i don't think anything
would happen
and what are you talking about
transformational i'm like i stipulate
that life exists go down to like the
river you know i'm in san diego go out
to the pacific ocean scoop up a glass
you know um you're gonna find life in
there and what are we doing what are we
doing to our earth
or destroying it callously we're like
pumping crap into there like we have
this toxic waste spill a couple months
ago in san diego i couldn't go to the
beach
let me take it a step further you know
how many you know how many people i'm
sorry that you do know but how many
people died in the 20th century killed
these are advanced civils this isn't
slime mold
we kill we maim we harm we hurt
we hate
i don't think anything would happen the
next day then we go back to what we had
and i said if that weren't proof enough
life has been discovered at least two or
three times just in my professional
career once in 1996
these allen land hills meteorites in
antarctica they saw like microbial
respiration processes still we don't
know it was a press conference held by
bill clinton on the white house lawn
that's featured in the movie contact um
repurposed for that movie
and um and then there's uh and then
there's this um the this phosphorus life
this this toxic life in the pools of
mono lake
many extremophile we don't give a crap
we continue to so why are we thinking
that like our salvati from whence will
our salvation come as the bible says
like it's not going to change how we are
it's not going to magnify how i treat
you or you treat me
and and we're pretty knowledgeable
people you and i compared to you know
lay people okay that's interesting
that's a really interesting argument i
wonder if you're right but my
intuition is
i can
i can maybe present a different argument
that you can think about in the realm of
things you care about even deeper which
is like what happens once we figure out
the origins of the universe like how
would that change your life
i would say there are certain
discoveries that even in their very idea
will change the fabric of society i tend
to see if there's definitive proof
that there's life and the more complex
the more powerful that
idea is elsewhere
that i'm not exactly sure how it will
change society
um because it's such a slap in the face
it's like a such a humbling force or
maybe not or maybe it's a motivator to
say
um yeah i don't know which force would
take over maybe it would be governments
with military
uh start to think like well
how do we kill it
if there's a lot of life out there how
do we create the defenses how do we
extract it or or yeah or mine it for for
benefits all those things i mean i just
see like there's a hundred million
literal counter examples about i mean
right now there's like like 700 million
kids in poverty and like we just how do
we go about our life and just not deal
with that i mean i look i put it aside i
eat hamburgers and you know in 100 years
i'll be canceled for being a you know a
carnivore or whatever but you know so
obviously to get through life you have
to make certain compromise you're not
going to think about certain things but
i i i just think there is a sort of wish
fulfillment like every time there's why
are we going to mars and digging and
flying this cool ass helicopter we're
looking for water like stipulate that
water was there
like i believe there was water i think
we should invest again and see what the
geology was like but but don't you think
so so you're saying i don't think you're
going to get meaning from it that's all
i'm saying i i'm not saying it's not
worth doing i'm just saying there's a
wish fulfillment aspect that people will
find meaning for life from science okay
but
there's a there's a complicated line
here what what if it's this
intelligent civilization
living
obviously probably not on mars but
somewhere like uh in neighboring galaxy
that we uh sorry in in in the name in a
neighboring star star system
that we discover
don't you think that profound change in
meaning i mean i guess again i assume
that because of this pan-ceramic process
or whatever that the probability is much
much greater than zero i mean it's not
one a hundred percent but it's it's much
likelier than that that at least some
living material from earth has
ejaculated itself into the solar system
into the universe right into our galaxy
please
as well that's right so ice like the
fact that that could happen and that
you're holding a piece you know from a
planetary body and one that couldn't
support life as far as we know uh but i
could get next time if
you if you play nice and you come on my
podcast someday i will give you a tiny
chunk of mars so mars theoretically
could support stuff right no no so yeah
so i believe that there's there could be
remnants of earth in this so so that
means there could be evolution i don't
think there's any chance that there's
like you know people using iphones and
having podcasts and stuff and and
probably so this is interesting there's
so much some chance though right
so again yes i think the pro well
obviously the simple statement to say
it's much much much higher probability
that life exists and technological life
exists right i don't think we can argue
that um it doesn't mean it's forbidden
again i'm not saying any of this is
forbidden not worth studying not
interesting it's a likelihood thing yeah
and to answer your i think you're wise
to push back and like what does it
matter what i'm doing
and i like to think about that you know
because it's like what is the value of
what you're doing like you have to
answer that question or else at the end
of your life you'll have these
existential you know kind of crises
right so when i think about like who i
am part of my identity is answering and
asking scientific questions
you